[Music]
the maker of tyndall plant-based chicken
says soaring food prices are good news
for the plant-based food market
reason why i say that the higher
inflation now actually helps us it's
because the higher inflation is coming
from gas where meat right that's one of
the the highest inflation rates and why
is that happening
it's extremely inefficient the resources
are becoming more and more expensive as
they become less available and this is
the market trend that actually is
driving the entire plant-based industry
so the scenario of high inflation for us
is not another issue it doesn't affect
us to the same extent that affects the
meat industry
and it only makes a plant base even more
attractive to consumers uh when you see
what's happening with the meat prices
that are actually doubling tripling
sometimes some percentages
andre says the cost of plant-based
protein will become cheaper than meat in
the long term
with a more efficient technology we use
less resources than meat then obviously
as the resources get less available or
they start to be charged today some of
the natural resources are simply not
charged that will
make meat super expensive that's one
angle that's fundamental to what it is
another one that makes plant-based foods
a bit more expensive today is the fact
that the scale is still not there it's a
natural progression as any innovation
anything starts at a higher price when
it's innovation as it gets scale and
volume it tries to cost down that's
what's going to happen plant-based as
well
next gen started with tyndall
plant-based chicken but it has bigger
ambitions
we wanted to make it global we wanted to
make it exciting we wanted to make it
versatile and innovative there is
nothing better than chicken to tick all
those boxes
our goal is to
go after every single category that
animal farming is today present our
competitive competition is actually
animal farming and we decided to start
with tindo starting with chicken
plantain chicken but we will then
compete against other categories it
could be against
beef and
pork and
fish seafood dairy anything anything is
possible
whenever there is any more farming we
will see that as a potential area for us
target